-We don't always have
enough time to cover
everything in the recent news,
so here with the recap is one
of our writers, Amber Ruffin,
in a segment we call,
"Amber Says What."
♪♪
-You guys,
things have been crazy.
Okay, first of all,
work was like,
"Amber, it's time to do another
'Amber Says What,'"
and I was like, "What? It's only
been a week since the last one."
And they were like, "The last
one was like a month ago."
And I was like, "What? Okay.
I'll come into work."
And they were like, "No,
we're still working from home."
And I was like, "What? Still?
Why? I can't stay here anymore.
I mean it.
There's a strange man in here."
And they were like,
"That's your husband."
And I was like, "What?
I married someone who judges me
for watching endless hours
of 'House Hunters'?"
[ Sighs ]
I'll try to make it work.
Okay, so Ben Affleck was seen
smoking while wearing a mask,
and I was like, "What...
are you protecting yourself
from, exactly?"
Do you think the cigarette smoke
cancels out the corona?
Oh, no,
I shouldn't have said that
because if Trump heard me say
that then he's gonna --
-It gets in the lungs,
and it does a tremendous number
on the lungs.
So, it'd be interesting
to check that.
-No! Dang it!
Too late.
So, then I heard
the governor of Florida
designated the WWE
an essential business,
and I was like, "What...
time is it on?" Because I would
kill for a new show right now.
I swear to goodness.
I have seen everything.
Whatever you have, I will watch.
So, then,
the actor Stanley Tucci
showed shared
this cute little video
of him making
quarantine cocktails,
and everyone was like,
"Ooh, Stanley Tucci."
And I was like,
"What? Stanley Tucci? Okay."
But then I watched the video.
-What are you gonna make me?
-A negroni. Would you like one?
-I would love one.
-Great. Would you mind
if I get my wine?
-No.
-Thanks.
-And I was, like,
in immediately.
All the way in.
I mean, what?
On top of everything else now,
I have to deal with having these
feelings for Stanley Tucci?
[ Sighs ] Alright.
And then --
You will never believe this.
Insane Clown Posse canceled this
year's Gathering of the Juggalos
because they, quote, "refuse
to risk even one juggalo life."
And I was like, "What...
a responsible posse of clowns."
Then, I found out that
there's a real-life little boy
in Australia named Corona,
and I was like, "What?"
Then I found out he was getting
bullied because of his name.
And I was like, "What?"
Then Tom Hanks gave him
a typewriter also named Corona
that he could use
to write him letters
so that they could be pen pals,
and I was like, "What?"
And then Tom Hanks wrote,
"You got a friend in me,"
and I was like, "Aww, what?"
Then I cried.
Not because it was beautiful,
but just because I feel like
the bullies are going to have
a field day with this.
Then, Cuomo has been
giving press conferences,
and I was like, "What?
These aren't press conferences,
these are TED talks where you
get to be bitchy like this...
and this.
But also informative like this.
This really tells you
what a low bar there is
for press conferences.
I mean, this man just told us
the day of the week,
and he has
an 87% approval rating.
Then I heard that Trump said
that people could cure
the coronavirus
by ingesting cleaning products,
and I was like, "What?"
The only cleaning product
I want inside of me is this guy.
[ Chuckles ] Just kidding.
It's actually this guy.
Ooh, Mr. Bubble.
Okay, so, now,
I'm sure, as you know,
a lot of states have told people
that they have to stay home,
and most people are like,
"Okay."
But last week, some people
in Wisconsin and Texas
were outdoors protesting,
and I was like, "What?
Why are these people
acting like this?
Oh, I remember."
If you tell Americans
it mostly affects black people,
folks will be outside
in a big pile,
French-kissing strangers
tomorrow.
I do not like to have called it,
but called it, I did.
So, then, Georgia said that they
were reopening movie theaters,
and I was like, "What...
is even playing right now?"
There are no movies out.
It's just gonna be that one
commercial that's like
♪ Let's all go to the lobby ♪
♪ And watch our grandma die ♪
So, then, President Trump was
like, "Drink bleach, everybody!"
And I was like, "What?
Yeah, baby, let's get wild!"
But then I found out
that there was no fun,
new cocktail called "bleach."
He was suggesting
drinking actual bleach,
saying it may combat
the coronavirus,
and I was like, "What?
That is the craziest thing
he has ever done."
But then I remembered
all the other times I said that,
and I was like, "What? What?
What? What? What?"
[ Sighs ]
This has been "Amber Says What."
♪♪
Give it up to Amber Ruffin.
We'll be right back
with Will Forte.